[Music]
all right ladles and jelly spoons we are
live on www.youtube.com/drzakirchannel
I said bananas sometimes - my days are
getting crazier and crazier these days
I've already taped three shows today and
I was up at the crack of dawn I did a
45-minute radio interview I had about
two minute breaks in between everything
and here we are we're going live the
second I'm done here there's already a
car waiting for me outside I'm heading
over to to do Tucker Carlson tonight and
then excuse me then I hear that that
that Trump fella is given a big speech I
guess I'll have to tweet that thing so
it's gonna be one of those days it's all
good what I wanted to do is as you guys
know I am departing patreon Sam Harris
has already left patreon Jordan Peterson
will be joining me on January 15th we
will be deleting our patreon accounts
this is all because of their treatment
of Carl Benjamin sargon of akkad I'm
sure most of you are well aware of that
whole situation so I don't want to
repeat the whole thing suffice to say
that every now and again in life I think
you have to just take a stand when it's
not easy to do so and maybe not popular
to do so and maybe puts yourself at some
risk and I just think this is the right
one for us to take patreon has been
amazing to us we've been on there for
about two and a half years you guys know
all the stuff about YouTube D
monetization and how hard it is to to
make a living as a YouTube creator
patrons been awesome for us I built a
business I bought a house I hired
employees everything that we've done
basically in the last two-and-a-half
years has been because of patreon but we
are deleting it it's time it's time to
stand up Jordan and I are working on a
platform that I think can be a solution
to this there are many layers of
problems that we're gonna have to deal
with but we're thinking them all through
about payments and crypto and the Terms
of Service and the whole thing you've
heard me talk about all of that before
so what we're doing today I'm only gonna
do two more one today and one on the
15th on January 15
two more live streams doing a little
fundraising because we're getting
everybody off patreon and we're trying
to get people over to Dave Rubin comm /
donate that removes some of the
middleman we can we can control
everything it doesn't solve all of the
technological or monetization problems
yet but get everybody over to our
website and and off of patreon and stand
up to the man so to speak so we're doing
a little fundraising so here's the deal
anyone that donates at dave rubin comm
so I should donate for the next hour
while I am live anyone who donates $5 or
above however you do it over there I'm
gonna give you a live shout out so I've
got an iPad here and my guys will be
typing out names you will get a live
shout out if you do $5 or above if you
do $25 or above you're gonna get the
Reuben report t-shirt now this select
member t-shirt this was the t-shirt that
we were given to our patrons who were at
the high level that were at the t-shirt
level so we've got about a hundred of
these left they will never be printed
again because we're not on patreon
anymore so select no longer exists so
these are the last ones they are a
limited edition collector's item ladies
and gentlemen I'm wearing one of them
right now maybe I'll have to give away
the one right on my back we shall see
so that's $25.00 or above monthly and
you're gonna get a t-shirt if you go to
$50 or above during this live stream for
the next hour I'm gonna take the
official Reuben report mug and what am I
gonna do to it I'm gonna sign it I'm
gonna show you how I'm gonna sign it
right here I'm gonna sign it for you and
you can get that mug so whoever does the
first $15 mug
the first $50 person monthly and it
signs up to dave rubin dot-com slash
donate you can get this mug that I just
signed right now there you go okay put
him that down so we've got t-shirts
we've got mugs and basically you guys
are funding our ability to keep this
thing totally independent we have had as
I've said we have had offers from
networks there's all sorts of
advertisers that want to jump on board
all sorts of stuff so none of this is
cry me a river and I'm not sitting here
woe is me or anything like there is
plenty of opportunity I love doing what
we've done the way we've done it
remained independent I am I am beholden
only to you guys and there's a certain
beauty in that because I genuinely have
I can't say I have no idea I have almost
no idea what most of you think about
anything so it's like I
really sell out one way or another or
any other way because I get emails
people that are conservatives I get
liberal emails I get us some angry
emails from progressives I get a lot of
emails from libertarians I mean all this
but I don't even know exactly what my my
patrons in the past and people who are
currently supporting this thing so I can
just do what I think is right which is
what I've tried to consistently do and
just what I'll consistently try to do so
ok if you go to Dave Rubin
slash donate $5 and above I'm gonna give
you a shout out 25 bucks in above
monthly you're getting the Reuben report
t-shirt and $50 are above monthly you're
getting a signed mug right now and
you're getting the t-shirt and I'll just
keep talking to you guys oh by the way
tomorrow I will be at the Ontario improv
not Ontario Canada I'm sorry to those of
you in Canada a lot of people were very
confused last time its Ontario
California which is I think it's about
an hour away Southern California I will
be there tomorrow night doing stand-up I
do about an hour set and then I will be
bringing Brett Weinstein professor in
exile Brett Weinstein formerly of
Evergreen State you guys I'm sure I'll
know his story he'll join me for a
sit-down afterwards and it's it's just
like a fun night it's not normal
stand-up like you've ever seen before
I mess around with the crowd a lot we
got people scream and I give away stuff
we do a live Q&A it's like it's like
just a free-for-all I think you I think
you'll really dig it so check that out
and oh and on January 20th I will be at
the Irvine improv in Irvine California
Orange County and I will have an ID w
guest with me not saying who that is
just yet okay we've got a couple shout
outs to Jared and Andy welcome aboard
thanks guys and Garrett you were the
first one that I saw so Garrett is
getting this mug let's make sure we put
this mug aside that was the first when I
signed and Brad welcome aboard you also
are getting a mug which I'm gonna sign
for you right now thank you guys you are
supporting our ability to do what we're
doing so as I said I'm only to do one
more of these and then I won't you know
promote or whatever you're going to call
this fundraise or drive whatever it is I
won't do it throughout the year you know
once a year I think we'll do it going
forward like one day where we're like
all right we're trying to raise some
funds to do this or that the next one
that I'll do and then it will be done
for all of 2019 will be on January 15th
we're gonna do
one of these I'll do a little giveaway
and some fun stuff and all that and then
I'm going to take my computer we have to
figure out how this is exactly gonna
work logistically I will turn it around
and I'm going to press Delete on patreon
right in front of you guys so you will
watch me delete patreon right then and
there we will get rid of that thing it's
no hard feelings to any of those guys in
a weird way it's like you want to run
your business that way I'm not gonna
have the government jump in and tell you
what to do but I just don't want to be
part of what they're doing anymore so
we're gonna do that on January 15th
Jordan and I also should have some
updates on things hopefully somewhat
soon things are move and trust me things
are moving just takes a little time to
get things done all right so let me jump
into some questions we'll also take some
questions on super chat I see a whole
bunch of you guys jumping in on that so
from patreon I got a question from
patreon about patreon do you have any
idea how much of a financial hit patreon
itself has taken because of the exodus
of you Jordan Sam etc so I don't know I
mean I could extrapolate if I was to
look at you know sort of the amount of
money that I know we were making per
month I have a general sense of what
Jordan was making per month I have a
sort of sense but less so of what Sam
was making per month and let's say a
couple other people patreon gets you
know like 5% of each of us per month
plus some other fees and things let's
say it's 10% total I'm actually not
totally sure it's it's a nice amount of
money but considering as far as I know
patreon got something like $450 million
dollars in VC funding in the last couple
years it's a small amount so I don't
think this is about while it is hurting
them in the pocket right and it's like
they want to make as much money as
possible I think that's taking the stand
is more important so look if patreon
crumbled after this that's not really my
goal here but like if it started a chain
reaction of people inside there that
suddenly weren't into free speech and
don't like all of this deep platforming
and are afraid of the way the line is
moving to exclude people I would be okay
with that
but this is more about us just doing
what we think is right but by the way
look people like brent Weinstein who I
just mentioned people like calamari
already I mean people that I love and
admire are staying on patreon for now
and maybe there's an argument to be said
that if you stay in a fight that could
be more effective but I also like the
idea of okay some people say stay some
people go some people write articles
about it some people talk about it on
social media etc etc there were more
than there's more than one way to skin a
cat so to speak so I think we're all
gonna hit it from different angles and
see what happened but I do think that
there is a technological and business
solution to this and that's where I'm
gonna put a lot of my energies although
it's pretty bizarre I got a I got a show
to run here which is a job unto itself
at or we just got an offer last night to
do live Reuben reports for all of April
taking me across America I'll be in
Australia with Jordan for most of
February I'm writing this book we're
probably gonna head back out on the road
in May and June with Jordan in Europe so
there's a lot cooking and now I guess
I'm a tech guy as well so you know we'll
see what happens shoutouts to Geoffrey
to Gunnar and to Richard and a mug for
Jared you're getting a mug thank you
very much guys really appreciate it you
guys are helping us do this thing and I
hope I hope it's look if you care about
these ideas then I guess it is worth it
do you let's see good luck on your
endeavor of creating a new platform
thank you very much make a blockchain
based payment service I can help hit me
up so I'm talking to a lot of people
based on well just I'm getting a lot of
recommendations let me say first about
doing a lot of this through blockchain
and taking more blockchain payments so
first off just on the blockchain front
we are taking payments right now for
we're taking Bitcoin payments at Dave
Rubin comm / donate and we've been doing
pretty nicely on there and you know it
goes up and it goes down and it's just
sort of something to have I think there
are more options where we're looking
into litecoin we're looking into
aetherium we're looking into ripple and
a couple of the others we're looking
into some blockchain based video stuff I
mean we're just scaling through all of
this and I see when I do these videos
now apparently a gajillion people are
watching these things because then
people start slicing and dicing every
word I said it Ruben said this about
that and he said this thing about that
thing and the other thing about that
it's like guys we're just trying to work
this thing through you know what I mean
it's a weird thing because I've noticed
that the amount of hate that I'm getting
these days has really ramped up and I
don't really care it's like I mute or I
block these people I give you just gonna
endlessly throw hate at me like I don't
care for you really it's like if I was
walking down the street and somebody was
like hey Ruben go [ __ ] yourself it's not
like I'd walk across the street and be
like oh should we talk about that knows
I'm not gonna do it online either but
it's funny cuz it's like I have so much
good stuff happening the shows going
great like touring and all this good
stuff and yet that isn't really what is
the marker of success in a weird way I
see all these people writing about me
and doing videos about me lying about me
constantly I'm like oh if I'm somebody
that they're doing that stuff about I
must really be a threat to these people
I guess I am successful so that's that's
actually pretty good
alright shoutouts to Christopher Joel
davidandnicky and Alexander you're
getting a mug here we go you've been
signed Alexander thank you very much
okay good luck sticking it to the man I
closed all patreon support I appreciate
it are you coming to New York City
anytime soon so we just got this offer
for live Reuben reports as I said in in
April basically the entire month which
would be pretty cool to be doing the
show in front of would be theater
audiences usually about a thousand
people one of the shows is in New York I
haven't signed on to the deal yet I got
it late last night and I haven't had a
chance to fully dive into it but that
could potentially be in April let's see
just change my $5 to 25 bucks monthly
send me a medium been funding for a few
years and got off the patreon train
before near your good luck I appreciate
it and when you when you submit via
PayPal or or your credit card we have
your email and then we can figure out
the sizes so that's how we do that
greetings from Argentina I love what
you're doing and what Jordans doing my
question is have you two considered
coming to South America so I don't know
why the the Jordan tour didn't make it
to South America I'm not sure it's on
the docket for what we're thinking about
in May and June I'll ask them ad I'm
actually not sure okay shout out to
Steve and tamari and thank you guys
appreciate it
thoughts on coinbase economically D
platforming gab so yeah I heard about
this and what's weird I guess and again
I I don't know everything about crypto
but I know that coin base is one of the
places I have a coin base account
actually coin base is one of the
exchanges where you can buy and sell
crypto apparently they booted gab but
not only did they boot gab if I'm
understanding this correctly they booted
the private account of the CEO of gab
and drew something or other I think his
name is
this strikes me as as particularly odd
like unless they're doing something
illegal but this is this is becoming
increasingly the problem we're gonna
slowly watch all sorts of maybe kind of
potentially shady people and I'm not
even saying that this guy is be pinned
off and we're all gonna think oh if I
don't say anything I'll be okay I don't
say anything I'll be okay but that's how
it comes for everybody because nobody
stands up so I'm very proud to stand up
with Jordan and see if we can figure
this thing out so I'm not happy when I
see any of these D platforming issues I
had lunch with Eric Weinstein yesterday
and one of the things that we were
talking about was that maybe what the
internet needs and this is an
interesting play on my my small
government beliefs is that look I don't
want the government telling these
companies - no - telling them what they
can do right you all know that ok but
maybe what we need on the Internet is a
public space so in other words if
everything's private online right now as
it basically is you've got all these
roads going in every rich direction
everyone can be on any of these
platforms the platforms can get rid of
anybody that they want but there's no
public space and maybe what we need is a
public space that is based let's say it
was made in the United States the United
States creates some sort of public space
online that stands by the principles of
free speech in the First Amendment and
beyond that as long as you aren't do
anything doing anything that is illegal
in the United States you could do
whatever you want so think about it as
like just a public park right so like if
you're at a cafe next to the park a
crazy person can't walk in start
screaming like they're allowed to kick
him out and that's what the private
company could do if they don't want the
person there they can kick them out but
that at least we would have a public
space a public platform for people to be
able to do it every day want that is
based in American laws and and the free
speech principles that that we all love
I think there's some way that pie could
actually sort of be for public funding
being for something like that that would
actually be interesting because in a
weird way if we only have private things
online then then nothing's really
private and I think that that's what's
happening right now so there's something
there I need to think it through a
little bit more let's see Dave
there one particular rule out of Jordans
book that help you the most what that's
a good question man well I tell you I've
you know I've obviously heard Jordan
lecture about the book you know 100 some
odd times and you know some nights I've
said this before but some nights he does
all too well you know lecture for an
hour and a half about all 12 rules
you'll hit all 12 some nights he picks
three rules and focuses on them some
nights he does one rule some nights he
does no rules and he talks about what
something else that's on his mind you
know I think God is there one that's a
hit affected me more than the others
well I it's cliche to say the one about
telling the truth right cuz like you
should try to tell the truth as much as
you can I'm always trying to tell the
truth as much as I can so I don't think
it's that you know the one about petting
a cat if you see a cat pet a cat and I'm
allergic to cats I don't like cats don't
pet cats in my estimation but he said
you can swap any animal for that I'm a
dog guy but in effect what he's saying
there is just stop and smell the roses
right just you know when things are
going well and you're in the thick of it
like don't get so lost that you don't
remember to enjoy it and when things are
going bad that there's still some
goodness out there kind of and try to
pause and remember those things so for
me right now my life is moving very fast
I have very little time to to come up
and breathe my I tried to take a
vacation around Christmas the whole
patreon thing happened and I didn't get
a vacation like I haven't had a lot of
slow down time but try to take those
little brief moments when there's a
little bit of quiet or a little bit of
something I played my nine-year-old
nephew and NBA 2k on PlayStation four
online the other day like just try to do
some things too whether it's petting a
cat or petting a dog or whatever it is
to enjoy a little of this the craziness
all right shoutouts to bud Rudy and
Theresa David you are getting a mug
thank you very much there you go David
- David and Joe you're getting a mug oh
I signed all these here we go got
another one down here thank you guys for
the support it is really appreciated on
super chat I found out about you via
Collin good luck on everything Thanks
so you're talking about Collin Moriarity
everything obviously I love Collin he's
a great guy he's been through the
outrage machine and the mob and he has
survived Collins doing
his podcast sacred symbols with with
Chris Raygun who you guys may know who's
also been on the show and Collins
staying on patreon and as I said in no
way do I judge him for it in in certain
respect I think having some of us on
there and off their offers the best form
of attack may be having some of the guys
stay on there still allows for them to
fight from within and maybe who knows
maybe you know between some of us go on
and some of us saying the the patreon
people jack conte and Jacqueline Hart
the head of trust and safety they'll be
like you know maybe we should alter the
Terms of Service a little bit not that I
would trust them because obviously Conti
came in here and lied directly to my
face when he said that you know you're
not gonna be kicked off over speech but
you know it's just another way of
dealing with things everyone everyone
does things a little bit differently you
know unfortunately the way the online
conversation is it's like everyone wants
to behave force everyone to behave the
exact same way and if you do anything
even a little bit different you're the
enemy and it's just like I don't think
that way and I'm not gonna live that way
thanks to Alexander to Douglas and to
David let's see uh Dave if Sargon had
used actual slurs against someone and
not just use a slur to quote someone's
language back at them and patreon had
banned them would you still have left
that's a really good interesting
philosophical question so okay so the
way for those of you that don't know the
wake Sargon was using the n-word in this
specific video that was not on patreon
and not even on his YouTube channel was
he was basically using the language of
the alt-right against them he wasn't
using the n-word as a pejorative so your
question is a good one if he had used
the n-word in a racially offensive way
would would this have resonated with us
the way that it did I don't know exactly
I don't well I certainly wouldn't want
to defend him the way that I'm defending
him right now like let's say let's think
about it if it was a friend of yours
right let's say you found out that a
friend of yours was truly a racist was
running around calling people the n-word
and didn't like people because of their
skin color or whatever that entails like
would you really want to defend them the
answer is probably no you might want to
you might want to find out more about
them and be like is this per the person
I knew and whatever that is
but would we have I guess your question
really is would we have seen this as the
opportunity to take a stand now if they
if he had been using the n-word as a
pejorative and in a racially offensive
way against specific people then it
would have made this a little more of a
messy situation where where patreon
would have more easily been able to say
you're not uppity that would have not
been on platform also it would have made
it Messier I think that's the best I can
say short of being in the exact
situation it would have made it Messier
I'm for I'm for all people to be able to
say whatever words they want I'm not
afraid of words you can call it people
call me all sorts of things you call me
a [ __ ] or whatever you want to call me
I will survive I really will it's crazy
someone says a word to me and I don't
crumble it's and it's incredible but at
the end of the day the I still believe
that these companies can do what they
want what is the solution well now I'm
coming around to this idea that a
there's a technological solution a sort
of decentralized solution but it's not
just that it's also the fact that maybe
we need these public spaces so what an
interesting spot to be in if you come
from a classical liberal or libertarian
position where you don't want the
government doing things that aren't
within its purview that you might go
well wait a minute this is actually a
good use of government this is a good
use of government dollars to be we are
gonna create spaces online platforms
that allow people to be involved in
conversations that allow people to be
playable to post video to interact all
of those things that are public space is
that the only there isn't a 27 page
Terms of Service that you got to look at
with your lawyer that nobody has before
you clicked except that the only rules
that you will have to abide by are the
rules that you have to abide by as a
citizen which are the rules of the
Constitution and your local laws and
things of that nature there's something
to that and I want to think about it a
little bit more reminder guys if you go
to Dave Rubin calm slash donate if you
donate five bucks or above I'm gonna
give you a live shoutout 25 bucks or
above you're getting one of the last
remaining monthly by the way 25 bucks
are above monthly you're getting one of
the last remaining Rubin reports select
t-shirts which will never be produced
again and for 50 dollars or more I will
sign a mug for you right now and you
get the t-shirt so there you go all
right here have some money since I'm no
longer on patreon thank you very much
that was from super chat okay curious
how you'll decide who will be allowed to
join the new platform keep it open verse
limit extremists so this is one of the
many things that we're discussing right
now we are discussing all this stuff
look if we open it up to everybody well
then you know what happens you're gonna
get all of the truly bad actors the real
racists and white supremacists and Isis
and all of the real bad guys then
everyone agrees are the bad guys you
know like that that are probably up to
criminal activity and all sorts of stuff
now as long as they're not doing
something specifically illegal I think
there's an argument to be made that they
can be on there and express their right
to express themselves that may not be
the platform that we are going to build
here we're really trying to figure this
out like that I'm not leading that
answer in any weird way like we're all
having sort of internal debate about
that do we want to do something maybe
the way the Internet is the the nature
of the the future of the Internet is
that not everything should be so big and
everybody should be able to get on there
and fight with everybody that maybe it
should be invite-only or a sort of
whitelisted thing something like that so
we're figuring out all of these things I
think you guys know me my general
position on this is I want as little
gatekeeping as possible I would rather
have as many voices as possible I would
rather have for all the people that have
been banned on Twitter it's like I'd
rather have all those people back and if
you don't like them you mute them or you
block them or you just ignore them but
this subjective way that they do it is
crazy so it's like so it's like Sargon
is also banned on Twitter or Milo is
banned on Twitter or Alex Jones is
banned on Twitter okay fine Twitter can
do what it wants but at the same time
say Farrakhan is on Twitter he said some
he called Jews termites and what did
Twitter do they took away his blue check
but they left him on there so it's like
you could stay on our platform but we're
not gonna tell people who you are I
don't know I guess that's something or
you know Hamas is on there so you know
like really awful groups are on there
but we select basically if you're on if
you're more on the right the groups that
get booted so it's this selective
enforcement and this this never-ending
amorphis Terms of Service that seems to
always hit
people on the right and not people on
the left look if you're on the left
right now anyone watching this any want
to test me right now
anyone watching this go on Twitter and
call whoever you want a white
supremacist you will not be banned it's
extremely damaging to call someone a
white supremacist and it's and it's
usually slander but you can do it and
there's no repercussions for it now go
on and call someone the n-word now I'm
not saying do that I'm not saying do
that but you get my point here is that
we've got a selected way we enforce
these things these companies can
selectively enforce if they so choose
but maybe we need an option outside of
these companies and that's what I'm
saying about that shout-out to Ryan and
to jord you're getting a mug brother
thank you very much welcome aboard
the future of the Internet okay um let's
see
would you talk to Peter Schiff privately
about if and how to incorporate crypto
or a different payment system other than
Kryptos he's a he's brilliant has been
on Joe Rogan's show a few times
I think we've traded some emails over
the years and for some reason it didn't
work out I'm not opposed to doing it and
I am exploring all sorts of other
financial options here we're trying to
figure it out that's that's what we're
doing there
get Bitcoin Jesus on the show I don't
know who that is but seems like an
interesting guy keep up the good work
okay
whoop-whoop donated 25 on the website
need an extra large shirt loved the
content if they hate you you're doing
good yeah I'm definitely coming around
to that one it's like all right you guys
gonna spend all day like can you imagine
somebody like waking up and it's like
why did Reuben do our on a livestream
what did he do it's like oh my god get a
life but that's more than anything else
it's just like what are you doing with
your life okay what are we doing here
guys I'm giving away mugs 50 dollars and
above monthly at Rubin report com I'm
gonna sign it for you or at Dave Rubin
calm slash donate 25 bucks or above
you're gonna give t-shirt we're gonna
send it out to you that's monthly and
five bucks or above
I'm giving shoutouts to anyone that
jumps in I am at the ER I'm at the
Ontario Improv tomorrow night with Brett
Weinstein and I am at the Irvine improv
on January 30th with and IDW men
TBD all right keep the questions flying
in guys shout out to Joshua thank you
very much welcome aboard this is on
super chat shout out to CBD American
shaman of San Antonio are you they
selling CBD legally in Texas right now
well I guess CBD can be sold this is
where I'm always a little confused about
the CBD situation but I have you know I
have a friend who hurt her shoulder and
she's been using medicinal CBD but but
out of cannabis and I think maybe if
it's in Texas you're getting bad of hemp
am i totally crossing this thing up but
anyone had a really bad shoulder she's
been used as a medicinal CBD it seems to
be working so there you go there's a
little CBD something for you keep up the
good work another one of those okay I
will
oh here's a whole bunch more I didn't
scroll properly which crazy lefty would
you most like to most like to interview
and I'd love a mug alright well you can
get a mug if you donate over a day
bourbon a concise donate which crazy
lefty let's remove the word crazy for a
second there are plenty of lefties I
would love to sit down with obviously
I'd love to sit down with Bernie and
Elizabeth Warren and certainly
Alexandria Cortez I would love to sit
you know I offer it up to the celebrity
types all the time so like a Rob Reiner
or a Judd Apatow or Sarah Silverman or
Chelsea Handler I'll talk to any of
these people okay as long as you don't
attack me personally or other people
that I know personally like if your if
your basic behavior is decent and we can
agree on what a conversation is I'll
talk to you but if you're going to
attack people if you're gonna lie about
people and all those things I just don't
want to do it it's just not a game I
want to be put I want to play go play
that game with somebody else okay where
are we I love that hyperspace painting
behind your couch keep it up oh yeah if
you saw the was did I do both of those
in there I think I did both of the
conversations with Jordan that's in my
in my living room it's a huge five foot
by six foot hand painting of hyperspace
so Millennium Falcon going into
hyperspace that was done by Kayla and
Janet by the way I think her website is
Kailen Rose Janet calm she also did the
painting that's behind me right now the
painting that's over there and a whole
bunch of other stuff in my house she's
really phenomenal versatile actress
actress she probably an actress too
artists who can do almost anything let's
see what are your thoughts wait have you
heard have you heard the beauty in the
beta podcast where a caller mentions
making an alternative to patreon he
mentions you by name it might be a good
idea to get in contact with him I
haven't heard it I did that podcast once
that's Matt Christensen who's been a
huge ally in this in this patreon fiasco
but I haven't heard that one
specifically but I can tell you that
I've had a bajillion people just reach
out to me here's an you know people are
just coming up with ideas - which is
also cool and it also shows you that
this thing is going to be solved by
human ingenuity not by the government or
not by just like the same old people
like I don't think it's gonna be the
same old tech people that solve this
right like I actually think it's going
to be new people that are doing it and I
wish I had time to respond to everybody
that's reaching out to me and all that
other stuff shoutouts if you donate it
Dave Rubin dot-com / donate okay and
there's a shout out for Brooke I made
that one happen quick okay let's see
this is from super chat coinbase is
problematic but you can still buy crypto
on their platform and then move it to
another wallet before sending it sending
to support - gab crypto is still the
best option for censorship resistance I
also sent you ten dollars in Bitcoin
well thank you for that yeah so from
what I understand if I'm really grasping
this all property you could properly you
could still forget putting gab aside for
a second just the principle would be
that you could still use coin base
because you can use it as your wallet
and then you can put your crypto at
wherever else you want to put it I got
one of these it's called the ledger and
that's like a physical device that I
have where I'm now keeping the crypto so
we're truly we're truly just trying to
figure this out alongside of you guys a
mug for Zachary you're getting a mug
Zachary here you go oh and somebody told
me but please confirm this before I
before I ruin this for you somebody told
me that so if you put these in the in
the washing machine
sometimes the signature is gonna be
written even though I'm using a I'm
using extreme fade-resistant sharpie but
it could wash off in the in the
dishwasher somebody told me that if you
bake the mug but I can someone
confirm this for me if you bake the mug
that the signature will stay in there so
I guess we will see about that the
meaning of life is to give life meaning
therefore isn't the key to life giving
big love to you and Jordan that's very
profound the meaning of life is to live
it delete it as I said it all right
there you go
let's see yo Dave crazy idea invite Joe
Rogan on the show he always does the
interviewing so I think it would be cool
to have him as the subject plus I think
you guys would get along for the most
part well I've been on Joe Rogan show
three times I was on there last time was
maybe May or June or so I had just
cleaned up flown in from Atlanta that
morning I think that was May I love Joe
he knows he's welcome anytime the guy is
beyond beyond beyond busy he doesn't do
that many shows he did do been Shapiro's
Sundays special which I gave him a
little [ __ ] for because he hadn't done
my show yet but I'm sure at some point
it'll be here so Joe if you're watching
because I'm sure you're just sitting
around watching these please you're
welcome on my show anytime he knows he's
on welcome anytime
shout out to Othman thank you very much
patreon canceling my patreon account now
you were the only person I was
contributing to so thank you very much
we'll start up on your website very soon
another one on patreon I set up a
recurring contribution directly on your
website and I'm gonna cancel my account
with patreon thank you for making me
aware and leading the way for my small
act of standing up to intolerance and
oppression thank you very much another
one on patreon I just now cancelled my
pledge to the Rubin report from my
patreon account okay did somebody
already get the old coffee table oh yeah
so I mentioned in the live stream the
other day that we've got out you know
this is our new set so we've got our old
set which are the old chairs we've got
two of the old guest chairs we've got
the old coffee table we've got the old a
lot of the old trinkets and things that
are around here some of the old artwork
I thought maybe if people make us like
some really great offers on that stuff
as long as we're raising funds right now
people could do that so we did get a
couple of hours they were they were kind
of low like it just wasn't worth parting
with them at that level so yeah if you
want to make a great offer you could
just email us contact at Rubin
report.com as I said we got two of the
the guest chairs I'm not getting rid of
my red chair because I still use that
what we do the three ways in here
but we got the coffee table and a couple
other things so you could check that out
will your old shows be accessible
somewhere I'm behind in my recent
retirement was gonna afford me time to
catch up that's from patreon I think
what you're referring to is that you
watch the show in the patreon feed so to
be clear a hundred percent of our
content especially if you're watching
this right now you're watching this via
YouTube the the video might be in the
patreon feed but this is all on YouTube
100% of our content will remain free it
will always be free I'm not putting
content behind a paywall the only thing
we've ever done behind a paywall is a
couple like behind the scenes things or
I ask a guess an extra question or
something like that we've never put any
interviews behind a paywall I am NOT
gonna do that I'm not starting a
separate show behind a paywall
or anything along those lines as long as
we can afford to produce the show as
we're doing it and hopefully expand a
bit and keep doing everything we're
doing and I can keep working on other
projects which can also help fund all
this you will you will be able to see
everything we've ever done so right now
if you're watching this person that
asked me that question every video that
we have ever posted anywhere it's all on
YouTube right now every interview we've
ever done so you can catch it there
shout outs to Tony Charles and Gary I
appreciate it thank you oh I get this
one a lot what are some books that
changed your life love the show and
everything you do Dave so I'll give the
two books that I most give and then I'm
gonna start coming up with a newer
answer for this on my bed right now on
my nightstand right now I keep a copy of
on Liberty by John Stuart Mill you can
read it in a day it's it's that thick
and it's just a wonderful explanation of
the individual and what liberty and
freedom are and it's a great explainer
of sort of classical liberalism as I see
it and then the other book that I would
recommend which I should have on set but
I don't cuz all the books that we have
on set actually are our books of former
guests and I wish I could have
interviewed this guy but he died about
maybe 15 years ago no he died I know the
year he died he died I think in 97 so
about 21 years ago if I'm not mistaken
Carl Sagan who is the incredible
scientist who did cosmos the book and
the television show his last book was
called billions and billions he actually
died before it finished and then his
wife Ann Druyan who's also a professor
at Cornell she had to finish it for him
and it was just sort of a broad
explanation it was
it was a little bit easier to read than
some of his other books which were a
little technical although he was an
incredible explainer of science it's a
broad sort of explainer about the way
the world is and the way he sees it and
what he sort of sees the future looking
like and it really just like sparked so
much of the things that I care about in
me
shoutout to Steven and a mug for Tom
thank you very much guys appreciate it
there you go tom
let's see why do you think crypto would
help be specific it's not a silver
bullet if you can't convert tender into
crypto it's useless
too many hoops to jump and the question
if you can't convert tender into crypto
it's useless but you can right now you
can buy crypto using tender so am I not
understanding the question maybe I'm not
understanding the question if you want
to clarify the question a little bit
more okay let's see Dave you should
consider inviting the author Robert
Greene on the show he's in California
would be a great fit
I'm actually not totally sure who I that
is so if you want to write a little bit
more I will check it out okay let's see
here's a second emphatic mode for
getting in touch with Peter Schiff a
crypto currency backed by gold his thing
is the most promising political solution
in my view all right noted I will let's
let's put Peter Schiff on the list guys
if he's not on there already he must be
on there already I'm okay how long do we
got here what time is it
337 I got 23 minutes left guys this is I
promise you this is the second to last
fundraiser of the year even though we're
in the first week of the year or when
that we're in a week of the day of the
year a week in a day of the year we're
gonna do one more of these on January
15th I'm gonna take my computer I'm
gonna walk over to the camera right over
there and you're gonna watch me delete
patron you know I should tell you
something about what's going on with
patreon right now so so you know I've
done obviously a bunch of videos about
leaving I have sent emails to my email
list about leaving I have we posted on
patreon that we're leaving I've put it
on Instagram I mean wherever you can put
it I put it
but right now despite all of that we
still have about 2,000 people that are
paying monthly on patreon and I think if
I'm not mistaken or last I checked the
day or so ago they were still
$14,000 a month of paying people on
patreon meaning that if I didn't cancel
patreon they would all be charged again
on February 1st so it's it's sort of
interesting because it's like people buy
into something and then you may not pay
attention to the day-to-day you may have
unsigned for even an email list let's
say and if you're not paying attention
on Twitter and you don't check YouTube
for a couple weeks or this or that or
the other thing it's like you may not
even know so it's such a weird thing
it's like I'm gonna say goodbye to this
money that in effect is like free money
but obviously I don't think it would be
right to say I'm leaving and then not
leave just to collect on that so we're
obviously not going to do that but it'll
be an interesting thing to see how much
how many people and how much is left in
the account when I do this a week from
today that would be that would be
interesting let's see um shout out to
Henrik thank you very much appreciate it
alright twenty minutes left guys Dave
Rubin calm / donate get yourself a mug
get yourself a Rueben select t-shirt
there right here I'm wearing one right
now I'm wearing a medium by the way if
that gives you any perspective on sizing
they're quite comfortable it's not like
one of those crappy t-shirts you know
those crappy t-shirts you put on they
feel like cardboard it is not that it
feels nice I think you'll like it my dad
often wears the t-shirt when he's
wandering around town and people say
item I want to take selfies with my dad
that's very weird but people wanted to
do it okay let's see what's going on
here I got get bitcoin Jesus on the show
I did that one already when are you
inviting Matt Christensen Christensen on
the show so that was mentioned already
about Matt yeah we'll do it at some
point I think he lives in like Montana
or Wyoming or something I don't know how
often he gets out to LA you know we can
do these things by Skype but I'm really
trying not to do them unless it's either
like a really big guest or somebody
that's international that really just
can't make it here but if it's someone
in the States that's mobile or whatever
I'd much rather do it in person also
right now just FYI were booked out all
through January we've got a gajillion
shows we're taping a ton of stuff some
really cool stuff oh and tomorrow we
taped this already I've got an interview
with behavioural scientist Jeffrey
Miller who is a really really sight
psychological behavioral scientist
Jeffrey Miller really really interesting
guy it was it was one of my favorite
interviews
in a while and I think we've been on a
nice a nice run here so that'll be a
part one - that'll be up tomorrow
let's see I'll donate a hundred bucks if
you answer these questions do you think
you will shave your beard soon the
answer is no I do love the beard and
people love the beard everyone that I
meet everywhere I go they want to touch
the beard they love the beard so I'm not
gonna shave the beard anytime soon
although when I got the beard which was
not last August but the August before
when I did my thing off the grid and I
just grew it and grew it and grew it and
then I trimmed it a little bit before I
came back on camera I thought I was
gonna maybe have it for like a month or
so but then everyone loved it and I
really liked it so I'm gonna keep the
beard also do you like jordan peterson
better with a beard or without a beard I
like him better with a beard I like him
better with a beard I think there's
something about you know his there's
something about his persona that a beard
fits it like his graying beard you know
he cut he's he's sort of the older wise
professor he's he's mentoring or helping
a lot of people you know get their [ __ ]
together and get their lives together
there's something that fits with a guy
in a beard right like if this was a
movie like he's the older professor with
a beard that's like teaching people some
stuff it seems like he would have a
beard that's like a Harry Potter or Star
Wars thing he would have a beard when
are you coming to Brazil no plans at the
moment yeah as I said I don't know why
we're not doing much in South America on
the Jordan tour I'll look into that a
little bit more I'm actually not sure
shoutouts to George - Nick and - Matt
you guys sound like you could be a
boyband
and and a mug for Dennis welcome aboard
Dennis there you go that that's a fine
signature right there you got a dentist
there you go okay what else is going on
here so wait what else can I tell you
there's been so many things happening at
once it's like it's hard to keep my head
on straight in the midst of all of this
oh you know I got a question for you
guys actually because you guys often
give me some good advice on some things
so I've I've shown her on video a couple
times but my dog Emma she's 14 years old
I love love love this dog I got her when
she was two years old she's actually
from New Orleans from Hurricane Katrina
and when the dogs got split up after the
hurricane they were sent all over the
country and I assume all over the world
actually they actually found Emma in a
box
uh and she had given birth during the
hurricane and she was nursing three
puppies and she was deathly sick because
they're drinking all sorts of oils and
in the water and all sorts of chemicals
and gross stuff that's in the water the
puppies were actually healthy she was
really sick the animals got sent all
over the place
she had a collar with no tags so they
didn't know what her name was so she's
actually had three names in life because
when she was in New Orleans she had a
name we don't know what that was then we
got her at the Humane Society of New
York which is a great little non-kill
shelter it's it's not associated as far
as I know with the maiden National
Humane Society it's just the one in New
York City it's on 57th Street between
first and second I think and we got her
there and they had named her Paisley and
then when we got her we named her Emma
and I had had her the first day I'm
walking her I got her walking her first
day in Central Park and this woman comes
up to me and says is that Paisley from
the Humane Society
I said yeah she said this is her son
Bernard and they went crazy they sniffed
but like only a mother and son could and
you know it was and we used to get
Bernard and and Emma together often
anyway Bernard ended up moving to North
Carolina but how bizarre like they went
all over the country and Bernard and
Emma both ended up on the Upper West
anyway and was about 14 right now she is
the greatest happiest one most wonderful
dog we get people but you know all my
guests come into my home because my
studio is here people that don't like
dogs end up absolutely loving her but at
14 she's she's not a young pup anymore
and I've noticed that she's a little
stiff and mostly in the back hips lately
so I'm thinking that maybe she has a
little bit of arthritis or something so
I'm looking at all sorts of supplements
and things that we can give her and I
know that you they want you to take it's
a little counterintuitive you'd think
you'd want them to rest more if they're
in pain but they actually tell you that
an older dog should be walked more if
they have arthritis because that keeps
them loose we can give them glucosamine
and chondroitin try saying that three
times fast and a whole bunch of other
stuff massages heat pads but if any of
you have any great ideas on that I would
love to hear them so please let me know
okay shout out to Pamela thank you very
much and a mug for Mike thank you very
much guys appreciate it you're keeping
the Rueben report totally independent I
shouldn't mention actually what that
means when I say we're completely
independent we are
100% independent period I am the boss
the buck stops with me that might be
good that might be bad I think it's
pretty good but we we treat all of our
employees great you know we take care of
a hundred percent of health insurance we
give nice bonuses I try to let everybody
be as free as they can be as long as
they're doing their job and we get that
respect back we've got a great little
operation here that I'm super proud of
and when I say we're independent we have
no it's my production company we we've
run it as we see fit the chances I'm
ever gonna fire myself pretty slim I
guess anything could happen but we're
free to do what we think is right which
is why when I'm getting these offers
from these networks it's like it would
take something crazy I'm not even using
this as a negotiating tool it's like it
would take something crazy for me to
have a boss and not be in a studio in my
home and all of these things like we
really did this thing right somehow and
knock on wood we can keep doing it
shout-out to Chaz in a shout-out to Luis
and just a reminder we've got about 15
minutes left that one week from today On
January 15th we will be doing a live
stream you will watch me delete patreon
live I'm gonna bring my computer right
up to that camera right there we're
gonna do it live patreon really proud of
you Dave there aren't many willing
people willing to stick their necks out
the way you and mr. Peterson are doing
2019 is going to be an exciting year to
say the least we will definitely be
switching contributions over to Dave
Rubin dot-com sesh donate all the best
thank you very much someone else on
patreon it's not so much that we are not
paying attention to the day-to-day I am
hoping that patreon figures this out
what they did for independent voices was
nothing short of amazing and I'd hoped
to be a creator myself they're the only
game in town and sort of and I want them
to come to their senses and rethink
their casual disregard for free speech
that's totally legit and that's why I
said for my friends that are staying on
patreon I get it for someone like like
right now like the idea that let's say
Colin for example Colin Moriarty who's
obviously been on the show and it's a
good buddy of mine for those of you that
are canceling patron patreon because of
me the idea that some of you might fund
Colin as well and now he's not gonna get
that that obviously doesn't make me
happy in any way that actually upsets me
but I think everyone just has to do what
they think is right like at the end it's
on you and you have to decide
what to do look like I suppose there's
probably some people that'll stay on
there for Colin and then donate
separately for me you know it's everyone
everyone or screw both of us whatever
you think is right there you go shout
outs to Lucille to Robert and to Dmitry
thank you guys
beautiful story about Emma Dave also
explained my last comment Robert Green
is the author of 48 laws of power you'd
really love his stuff let's get the book
can somebody write that down well we'll
get the book there we go and see what
happens there
keep it up Dave please donate my t-shirt
I don't know if you're saying you're
donating a t-shirt to us or something
else but thank you
I've spent a thousand plus hours
building a patreon alternative with
anti-censorship features in the past
year what would be the best way to get
in touch and present it to you guys so
I'm getting all sorts of offers like
this and it's a little hard to track
like who's legit who is and I've had
some phone calls with people that I
think have been really interesting and
some kind of go nowhere contact at
Reuben report.com is the best way to do
it my guys kind of go through it and the
most important ones get to me and then
if you're if you're really on to
something here
I hope so and then we you know we do a
zoom or a Skype or take a call and go
from there super Chad I appreciate your
willingness to stand up thank you very
much
super chat the government / payment
processors could stop you using crypto
if they really want to especially the
ones with transparency built-in like
Bitcoin so this I need to learn more
about this I fully admit that like I
don't fully understand how the
government if you were doing all the
transactions were on crypto where crypto
based how would the government be
tracking that now I guess they could
track if they had the specific Bitcoin
number or the wallet number wallet
address they could track what's going in
there I I need to learn a little bit
more about this guys I'm you're watching
me do some of this stuff on the fly like
that's just the truth shout-out to David
there you go oh you know speaking of
doing some stuff on the fly something
funny happened the other day so I did
this live stream just like this and you
know I'm taking questions alright and
you guys can see these questions you're
just flying in right and my guys color
code them sometimes if they think
something's like particularly important
for me to get to or that I need to read
it quicker or whatever it is right
and so the other day I took I don't know
I took fifty questions I have no idea
and I'm just reading them on the fly I'm
they're not censoring them and then
someone asked me something about Brazil
and I said one little thing about how I
need to know about I need to know more
and then all of these people started
writing all these articles and doing
these videos about how I'm backing a
dictator in Brazil and I'm a fascist and
the rest of it it's like man like Bill
Kristol formerly of the Weekly Standard
which just folded he retweeted somebody
saying something about me and it's like
what are you people talking about I said
one sentence in a two-hour live stream
you're taking it totally out of context
and I admitted I need to know more about
the topic like this sort of desire to
destroy everybody it's like it's gonna
destroy you guys it ain't gonna destroy
me it's gonna destroy you guys and
serving Lee so let's see Dave is the new
platform gonna be a hundred percent
geared towards free speech or is it
going to be an echo chamber I promise
you it is not going to be an echo
chamber as I've said we're trying to
figure out what the parameters around
that mean is this an absolute place for
everyone I mean I can be very clear I
don't want people doing criminal
activity I don't want child porn on
there I don't want terrorist activity on
there so an absolute free speech space
within the content confines of the law
my goal is yes but we have to figure out
exactly what that what that means and
we're working on it all right guys we
got ten minutes left so Dave Rubin calm
slash donate you guys are the lifeblood
of the show you've already shown up for
me here today as you have last time I
promise you were only doing one more of
these in this entire year we're knocking
them out by January 15th we will not do
any sort of fundraising for the rest of
the year we're doing well we've
obviously we took a huge hit on patreon
and I'm now forcing it but we're making
up a nice amount of it on our own
website Dave Rubin calm slash donate
it's a short stopgap measure of getting
rid of the middle guy if you donate 50
in the next 10 minutes I'm gonna sign a
Rubin report mug for you if you donate
25 monthly in the next 10 minutes I'm
gonna send you this t-shirt and if it's
you 50 you get t-shirt too okay let's
see um find a chiropractor it saved my
boy's life oh I think you're talking
about your dog all right yeah Oh find a
dog find a dog chiropractor it saved my
boy's life yeah
yeah I read that there are actual dog
chiropractors so I may take her to one
of those we'll see about that
dr. John Bergman studies on reversing
arthritis may help you with Emma as a
side note dr. Jos Dispenza is a great
guest choice so I'll look and I'll look
into both of those can you guys write
those down thank you guys for that I
really appreciate it
let's see I'm a conservative and I just
bought a mug but I wanted to give the
mug to a liberal teacher of mine because
your show gave us common ground could
you sign it for her that's awesome
I can email you the info yes I'd be
happy to do that Helen we'll keep an eye
out so email us contact at Reuben report
comm remind us about this and I will
sign it directly to her and you can give
it to her that's what it's all about
that's what it's all about people don't
hate each other for the most part like
there are good liberals there are good
conservatives there are even good
progressives I think their ideas are all
terrible basically right like you guys
know that I don't that doesn't mean I
think they're all terrible people are
many of them I think confused sort of
logically and and and morally at a
certain level yes I think so but I don't
think they're inherently bad people do I
think that their think that they're
doing their right thing yes I think
those things are the wrong things but
that's why we got to care about facts so
it's like when when aoc the other day
she said this thing about you know too
many people get hung up on on facts and
making sure everything's exactly right
as opposed to what's morally right what
that's a pretty dangerous thing to say
because we all have different morals one
of the topics we've spent in the last
year talking about most here's where the
morals come from and the difference
where you know Sam Harris says morals
can come from facts that you that are
sort of right in front of you and we can
figure out what we can derive value and
meaning from fact some people been say
and and Jordan would say that comes from
a judeo-christian ethic it doesn't
matter what the answer is but the point
is we believe different things are moral
but I don't want politicians who are on
a moral crusade I want politicians who
look at the government they go this
should be as least intrusive as possible
and we're gonna get out of the way and
we're gonna let people live freely and
that's gonna be a little messy and it's
gonna be not everyone's gonna get
whatever they want but we're not gonna
keep taking from everybody to give to
some and we're not gonna just we're not
involved in every facet of everyone's
life most bad things that have happened
in the course of time have been done by
government and we have to really
remember that okay
shout out to Lisa there you go all right
guys we've got six minutes left give me
some good questions to end up strong on
best of luck Dave another best of luck
we got a whole bunch of best of Luck's
okay
do you like many our chasm in
libertarian political philosophy a night
watchman state or many our chasm minier
chasm i guess is a model of a state
whose only functions whose only
functions are to provide its citizens
with the military the police the courts
thus protecting them from aggression
theft breach of contract and fraud and
enforcing property laws I mean that's
not that far from what an ideal
libertarian state would be so I would
need to know what do you mean how is
that different than what just a basic
libertarian state would be I mean I'm
for I'm for and as much as possible the
state's each individual state deciding
what it wants to do if it wants to tax
high or tax low and that maybe that's
gonna either bring in business or loose
business I'm for States deciding whether
they want marijuana to be legal or not
and maybe that's gonna bring people in
and help the economy or maybe it's gonna
force certain people to leave I'm for
States deciding how much tax money they
want to take to put into education
versus whether they want to put it into
funding a baseball stadium or whatever
else I want that experiment that
incredibly beautiful American experiment
of testing this and that and seeing what
works and seeing where people move and
where they stay away from and where
freedom prospers and where people can
make the most out of our lives and and
what laws cause people to leave that
that experiment is awesome to me and I'm
for anything that would lead to more of
that so what you just laid out there for
me it's pretty congruent with most of
the things that I believe but I would
need to know a little bit more let's see
super chat Josi being a patreon being a
patron isn't enough what am i buying
here I don't know that you're buying
anything but it has been nice getting to
know you a little bit that that is
actually one of the things one of the
things is that I've been able to meet a
lot of these patron people and I've had
dinner with some people and when I was
on the road with Jordan I would get
coffee with people and chat with people
there's something cool happening here
there's something cool all right we got
four minutes left people these are your
last chances right now during this live
stream to get the mug or the t-shirt I'm
gonna sign mugs how many more here I got
four in this box right now can we get
rid of all these four I got a whole
other box right here but I got four
remaining and that you know what if you
do it for these last four
because we got four minutes left I got
four mugs for these lat anyone else that
gets on until we shut down in four
minutes I'll actually put your name on
it too
there you go rube Dave Rubin Hakam slash
donate 50 bucks monthly you're gonna get
the mug I'm gonna put your name on it
and you're gonna get the t-shirt and
you're gonna feel good about yourself we
should be selling totes okay
all right Tanner and Eric I'm writing
your name
there you go Tanner and Eric I don't
know if you guys were signing up before
I did it but Tanner you're getting a mug
Tanner I even put an exclamation point
after your name that's exciting and Eric
with a CK the rare CK Eric all right
very good Eric you're getting a mug Eric
Eric you got a comma I gave I gave the
other guy an exhibition Brandon thank
you very much all right guys getting rid
of these last couple mugs right here de
broom com / donate we got three minutes
left I talked a lot today I mean try to
imagine I did I did two full-on
interviews then I did a half-hour
interview then I did I started the
morning at 7:00 a.m. with a radio
station in Altoona Pennsylvania I think
which actually was totally fun let's see
why Oh this is a great question
why is the Reuben were based out of
California if that states economic and
political climate is as bad as
conservatives say is it exaggeration out
well I don't think it's as bad so first
up the taxes here in sane they're
absolutely insane now I do have a
business here so I'm able to write off a
lot of stuff right so if we buy a whole
bunch of mugs we're able to write that
off as a business expense obviously
there's some other things that we're
able to write off that you know business
expenses when we buy equipment and
computers and things of that nature so
that helps a little bit on the tax front
why is it here I mean the main reason
it's here is that in LA specifically is
that well a I moved to LA it'll be six
years in February and when I moved to LA
it was sort of at the beginning of all
of this and I was just trying to get a
gig that I thought was cool and whatever
I hadn't really sort of figured all this
stuff out what I would say now is I mean
first off SoCal LA the weather
is great like it is 80 and sunny almost
every day the worst day and SoCal is
like the best day almost everywhere else
instead of San Diego but you're gonna
pay for that because a lot of people
want to live here obviously but but
that's not it although I do enjoy the
weather for sure the real thing that
keeps me here right now is that there
really is a nice thing growing in Los
Angeles a nice sort of center-right
classical liberal libertarian
conservative thing growing right here in
LA I mean look Ben Shapiro is here Peter
teal just moved down here Dennis Prager
is here but then there's other people
that aren't don't necessarily fit into
that sam harris is here i mean there's
there's a lot of people in the los
angeles area you know because the thing
is that as politics as politics collide
more with media right and as politics
becomes more invested in what's going on
with the digital world and youtube and
all that well now and la is the home of
entertainment and now politics is kind
of becoming entertainment now that may
be terrible for the long-term health of
the country but it's something that's
happening right now so i think this the
the whole Gestalt of that i would say is
the reason that I'm here Gestalt good
word by the way all right guys we got
one minute left
how many more mugs am I going to get rid
of we will be doing another one of these
on January 15th when I will be shutting
down patreon live right here it's Dave
Rubin com / donate and here's what we'll
do just in case you're about to sign on
right now because it is four o'clock and
I got to go I think the Tucker guys
waiting for me outside
anyone that donates in the next 10
minutes till 4:10 we're gonna shut the
stream in a sec but if you don't in the
next 10 minutes well and you get the mug
I'm gonna put your name on the mug
itself anyway we'll do another one of
these next week we got Jeffrey Miller on
tomorrow
we got another bunch of cool shows
coming up over the rest of the month
then I hit Australia for most of
February with Jordan then I'm back here
in March and we're all ready we're like
overbooked already but we'll leave some
room in case some interesting things pop
up then I may take the Rubin report on
the road for April I got a look at that
deal and see where we're at on that then
Jordan and I may hit the road again or
it sounds like we are for May and June
back to Europe and yeah let's just keep
going right why not when you got better
to do so thank you guys thank you
everybody that just donated you guys are
the lifeblood of this thing you're
keeping it going
we're gonna be okay like if we don't get
any more donations we're gonna be okay
but the more we get we can keep growing
and expanding and all that stuff but but
truly when I when I said we were leaving
patreon I did not know what was gonna
happen like I didn't know if we said
okay well people go to our website like
I didn't know if we were gonna wake up
and it was gonna be like 15 people went
there and we got a couple hundred bucks
I'm like I gotta lay off people or like
figure out something else to do
but you guys have shown up you really
have it's it's it's incredible it's
humbling it's awesome you make me want
to be a better man I am looking forward
to seeing some of you guys tomorrow
night at the Ontario Improv in SoCal
with Brett Weinstein January 30th at the
Irvine improv January 29th on that Cal
State I'm blank and where am i Cal State
somewhere yeah I think I'm at Cal State
the the College Republicans are inviting
me I would have been glad to talk to the
College Democrats but they they never
invite me anywhere and all right that's
it catch me on Tucker I think I'll be on
at 8:45 Eastern which is about 5 or 15
minutes before this Trump guy is given
to talk about the wall so all right I'll
see you guys around thanks a lot
[Music]